Hãy bỏ lốt chiến dần à hành hoàn tháng 2 theo dợi.
Tổng thống Mỹ đô nên tròa mạng trình bài thông đều đứa bằng ngà mãi nghiênh không chào mì sấu tại điện
Kẹp Chổ với Chủ Để.
Nếu Mỹ hai chăm năm năm, mạnh mẽ thì vượng và được tôn trọng.
Trong bài phát biểu đường tiên của những kỹ thương hai, tổng thống trong khẳng định.
Nếu Mỹ đang bước phà một thời đại hoàn kým, nhấn mạnh các kết quả việc kiểm soát phát,
tăng trưởng kinh tế, thu nhập phát, niềm bình dưới.
Tổng thống Mỹ cũng đề cập cử ư tiên đối ngoại, bao gồm bài trò trung sang trong kết tiên trình đàn phát của tế,
và nỗ lực cùng có vị thế của Washington trên trường của tế.
Bây giờ, chính xích hơi quan nhập cư và ngân sách ăn nền nội điện.
Được xem là những lửa dung chẳng tâm trong trình trình gị sử sắp tới.
Bởi vì giết xác kia nghĩ, chúng bị bố phà của bầu cử giữ những kỹ trong trường thường đầy một năm.
Chưa bố cảnh các cuộc thăm só trưa thấy, nhau ý kiến chái chiều bị hiệu quả điều hành kinh tế.
Giờ kiến phía rảng dân chủ sẽ đưa xác phản huy ziêng tập trung vào giv xinh hoạ phúc lợi xá hội và các vấn đề dân xanh.
Này là thông nghiệp liệu bằng đầu tiên trong nhập kỹ thứ 2 của tổng thống trường trường.
Gián xa trong đường đề điểm đảng dân chủ đang xa phang trí chế cậm thống và cân nghĩ sẽ cộng hoạ.
Bây vấn đề giv xinh hoạc, chính thua tự mang lại lợi thế cho học trong một số của bầu cử điện phương năm 2018.